he's one of the Great's of all time on
the court and we just heard him talk
from last night on inside the NBA he is
none other than Shaquille O'Neal how you
doing Shaq you there Shaq I'm better for
talking to you
life's good life's good for you well can
you give a little bit more I guess
thought on on embiid we just played your
comments from last night I assume you
still feel the same way that he needs to
[Music]
the Consensus feels you know I don't
play when all the greats played you know
they expect you to do great things when
you show us greatness people want to see
it and then Mark Jackson cities he
should be in consideration as the most
one of the most timely big man's one of
the great big picks because every place
they ask well that's a big compliment
when you guys said that about me
I know that meant one thing you gotta
step up you gotta hit free things you
got to make a play you got to bring this
city a championship now if he wants the
process to be an amazing story all I got
girls win two games two games in a row
he has to still have two beautiful games
bro and this conversation times you
complain about being sick will be
forgotten
listen I'm all he's probably hurting but
how many great players have stepped up
and perseverance I hurt him with George
money getting food look older what he
had a flu game so it's not bad you know
nobody cares what's what's the most sick
or hurt you you were ever Shaq when you
were on the Olive lizard I play about
uploading my whole career to a maggot
accretion nobody anti-inflammatory shots
I had to take you know because this milk
that's what my father always told me if
you can walk you can play so my injuries
like evaluate I was just jumbled the
dollar okay
I can walk I think up I can play cuz
nobody cares and I learned that from
my military girls logic bother clue on
Thursday then I tried to be cute oh I'm
sick you said what excuse me you're sick
not on us can you walk yes you are yes
sir we'll get your heads in the game
we'll play solos people paying money to
pay all these kids can come up to you
nah you can't be sick but then a couple
weeks later he took me to a place called
Walter Reed Hospital and in with
soldiers and just came back from in the
war amputees you know burn marks mala
and you know what they want to do they
want to go back to Center country and
then my father say this is why you
should never complain I know I want him
to do well so ok but nobody cares it's
done with her channel but you can get it
once you close those lives you got a
complete well shack I mean you say you
know him and and and anybody who does
know him knows that he's smart
you know I mean he gets it he's a guy
who gets it I mean what do you think
he's learning it right now or needs to
learn what you're you and Charles were
counseling with some tough love one
would say last night do you think he
knows do dental D when you've been
through the battles rolling in you know
you come out you know what you're
talking about
so a lot of these youngsters just don't
know okay with your answers to the test
you want to be great this is how you do
it
I know for a fact I'm saying greatness I
play with greatness
I am sure I played against the greatness
and I know what it takes
Shaquille O'Neal here the bottom is
Jordan 45 finals hey mr. Jordan you want
to win early or you want to sit here
only you talking about mass appeal again
I said well you know just give me some
water again once you step on my court
you can beat cop we had a small game to
where he hit 40 and he really was saying
I was there seen it
mistake I guess once you cross onto
closer
and then their ball went up in the air
you go to work so look I'm just and he's
hurtin but nobody cares you know how
nobody cares Twitter is killing
everybody still though you guys are
killed
oh man again but again the process would
be a hell of a story if it's just one
these tips it's right I hope here's
everything I saying get mad and come
down today so that's what sports all
about Sachi when I stick up for the big
guys because I think too because time
come back Tim joke itch
no well I was about to turn to that
check with the jock itch last night
we're wondering if he's one of the best
second round selections in recent memory
uh so what what do you think of what he
has done here Shaq and how Denver can be
a long-term threat to win the title this
year he's a mixture of whole school a
little school any place right with
cancer none bad about the kid as a great
player he makes all the other guys
around him better he plays at his own
pace I can step out of the shoes what
made you thanks for exactly the place
and he's a showman really like watching
the secatur play so what do you think
happens tonight Golden State in Houston
Shaq what do you think at Golden State
yes sir you go to say the win tonight
tonight because those guys know how to
step up and others Bob clay and blue a
lot of time on staff didn't play or less
huh
which means too pissed off I don't want
to play against insist on playing steps
because they know what it takes they
know what they got to do probably got a
couple guys out there at count them all
great players this is what we need
sometimes called you as your lovely wife
will know very soon I would always look
for what Dale Pulaski had to say what
the guys on ESPN have to say which you
had to say and what I read and I get
into the POV the pissed off but excuse
me the plz the pissed on song yes play
so you know those guys aren't really
shooting well I saw something in Vegas
where the laws that
those guys here on this dough yeah
they'll be ready yeah take another wing
no I have to run usual a big step up
I would like to see this year's go seven
new tonight a one seven and Houston loss
and then everybody well we have a
healthy team Chris Paul well Chris Paul
is there now so let me go seven and then
just play one game to see who moves off
there's no sports and basketballs all up
and Kyrie is he in the poz right now
Shaq what do you think about him tonight
I hope so you know his comments last
night about somebody else what will
leave little going 16 / 17 for 67 he
said I don't care I think baby that
wasn't wrong answer
cousin Cho said yeah well that's what
the other guys in this room we can't
make sense and what you also have to
understand as a young player that once
you say to America I want to be the man
I want you to use I want to be the man
Teddy who wears the crown
you can't go 617 for 67 on the plastic
that's what you're gonna get all the
blame
and the real ones accept that okay you
know what we tell them everybody we're
gonna bring a championship to this video
this was called superstar superstar you
know it's about people liking it it's
about perseverance about stepping up to
challenges
it's about doing the impossible if you
won't be considered coach you got it to
it it's been done before
remember Kyrie blessing wrong because
he's done I want to be a sidekick I want
to be the man now that you the man you
got to step up you don't step up means
evil me you guys gonna be token so we'll
say no you're going on and then it's
gonna be more robust as you staying
he's going back to joins brother right
can you handle it is he going to New
York
is he gonna get to Supermax and this is
co can always used to like I think you
know I can do it
you liked that is that what you're
saying you of course I loved it you know
I liked it because
now I want to know look at magic look at
bird look at my girlfriend dr. J look at
look at Bill Russell look at Corinne
look at all the stuff look at mr. Jordan
but they're all let's dump the antidote
it'll be great yeah I want to be
considered one of them sorry I like it
mmm except oh yeah you know my psycho
Shack just filed on yourself
how many 3,000 at night how many times I
drink all through especially in the
finals hmm
so yeah well they want you if you have
any doubts any of that you won't do well
you have to just you know go outside
pull the stool topicals jump so if you
had to choose a few more minutes left
with Shaquille O'Neal prior tonight's
doubleheader on TNT bucks hosting the
Celtics trying to eliminate them and
then Golden State in Houston in the
pivotal Game five to wrap up the
doubleheader tonight if you had to
choose who's had a more disappointing
playoffs Kyrie or embiid what would your
answer to that Shaquille O'Neal know I'm
really terrible but you have to
understand that when when I'm telling
these guys I'm also speaking from sex so
I want to say it's disappointing because
guess what you could have three bad
games and in the games that count if you
close those up this will all be
forgotten
so one sentence have more disappointed
however if you 28 in the regular season
and you drop down to 18 especially this
round that's not good and I was told and
I was told that your PPG you gotta add
five
sometimes you gotta add seven and the
great ones ass kid so you know and
that's called the indominus and that's
called you know getting to the next well
I'm not a doctor borders are terrible
upper respiratory infection what does
that I don't I don't know
it sounds like a bad cold to me very
cold yeah like maybe you're you're just
among I don't know yeah I don't really
travel on planes I have no idea Richard
stop it stop
well I don't think he was faking it I
mean I know that I uh
we'll look what does that have to do
anything I don't know the arms work your
legs work can you run can you jump man
this is part of the reason why I love
you Shaquille O'Neal first of all let's
review just a couple things here before
I let you go I wouldn't bet whenever you
got in the poz pissed off zone I wasn't
anything from what I said first of all
my wife would have killed me Suzie and
then secondly no but even if you dismiss
okay thank you okay
all right then I guess you're well I'll
take credit those no serves everybody
that closely it's to see again in our
profession and I know a lot of guys
listen to this but however I belong or I
can get on this yet for a second so like
even if he said something crazy I'll
watch it and I listen and I be real with
myself rich so most of the time about me
it was about $3 per share boom boom boom
and you can't get mad about that
resistor 2010 but I get this off that
you know I cannot get my respect I think
people don't think I'm playing st.
tempted also like I would say all that
stuff oh he's only stable Robison I will
make a book you give me an autograph
when I kill him so all this stuff was
stuff that motive it well I mean it's 49
but if you have made to touch that I'll
take it
you never be a great big man once on
custom grass you are we're on a great
big plan services but you are who you
are Shack and that means you're also
still on the poz
like you were with Charles and Kenny and
the other day I mean it's tough when you
get on the poz I could see it on the air
because again I thought guys like SAP
get in the poz Irv's gotten in the poz
on the air with me and it's tough to get
you you know all-time great athletes out
of the poz on the air I felt for Ernie a
little bit there but he started laughing
how long does it take you to get out of
the POC on inside the NBA
yeah probably well ten minutes
hmm because you know the with those guys
even though I get it why not guys aren't
are you
excluded earnings like you collections
you can say whatever you want to say you
just have to take it
okay King Chuck well they gave me an a
zone I know that I can do that too and
physically because we're brothers so I
don't know the Everly Brothers rich but
I'll show you without people like your
brother so it's just like how your
brother stares out there you mad about
it but you get over nine all love and
all respect it's funny because there's a
little honky Charles Barkley I will
never do that anymore
older louder brother it's fun to watch
I'll tell you that because they love
what may know they could I could see
they know you're in the poz and they
just like brothers they will continue to
poke you a little bit and laugh because
they know you can't get out of being
pissed off on the air check I saw it
thanks for the call man I look for
watching you tonight you're the battle
okay I own you for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app